we're all one decision away from
massively changing the direction of our
lives we can take one drink and get into
our car we can sleep with someone that
we shouldn't have and destroy marriage
um or we can quit a job or we can sell a
company and so one of the things that's
always been interesting to me is that
billionaires millionaires hundred
thousand heirs people who are have zero
dollars people who are in massive debt
the only real thing that distinguishes
these people is the quality of their
decisions and so what i wanted to do in
this video is walk you through the
decision process that i went through in
selling the majority stakes of three
companies for 50 million dollars last
year um and my name is alex mosey and so
i i make this stuff because i want to
document the journey mentally for me
because i think i'm going to forget the
details of these things as i age and
like kind of what i was thinking and and
the different pieces of it and so i made
this little presentation based on notes
uh because i actually took really
extensive notes throughout this entire
process of what i was thinking through
you know different variables i was
considering because this is not a an
instant decision the the whole process
for me actually took almost 18 months um
and a lot of deliberation a lot of back
and forth all right and so that's what
i'm going to kind of focus on in this
video so uh to sell or not to sell so
there were seven variables that i looked
at one was kind of the story externally
and internally the second was money and
finances you know for me uh personally
third was kind of energy and headspace
the fourth was team resources in terms
of like what am i going to lose am i
going to gain number five is the future
and the vision for myself number six was
what was the best decision for the
business and then number seven i'll loop
around and tell you what i ultimately
ended up doing and why probably more
importantly why all right so my name is
dr mosey my wife and i are business
investors and we and safe portfolio
companies do 85 million a year and i
have nothing to sell you and if you're
you know here's your youtube proof
because i know there's a lot of people
out there so you can just google apg gym
launch and you can see all the top
results are you know public disclosures
of them purchasing making a big
investment company out of 46 those two
were at a 46.2 million valuation the
third sale i can't disclose the number
the company did 12 million the year
before i'll just tell you that okay so
quick backstory i actually ended up
writing out the backstory for this
in in more detail so this will get you
100 up to speed to the same context as i
had so i spent the better part of two
and a half years obsessing about a
single decision whether or not to sell
my business and i'm thankful to tell you
that two and a half years later i made
that decision so what i want to walk you
through is how i made it and hopefully
help someone skip the two and half years
of mental trudging that it took me to
get here so let's start with why did i
want to sell so let me take you back
into a moment that i decided to sell and
then bring you forward to this moment so
leila and i were on a walk in march of
2019 and we had just done 4.4 million
dollars in revenue that month and taking
out 1.7 million in owner dividends that
month she stopped and she looked at me
and she said let's shut it down i don't
feel like doing this anymore we don't
need the money let's just shut it down
and move on and being the motivated
money motivated entrepreneur that i was
at the time i was like hey now let's at
least see if we can sell this all right
maybe we can get like a small payday
before moving on to our next thing and
so i went up and hit my network up and
asked anyone if they knew anyone who
could help me you know value my business
uh and let me know what somebody might
pay for it and that's when a good friend
of mine rick mayo introduced me to
investment banking friend of his who
specialized in our space which is the
fitness base at the time
and so within a day or two i was on the
phone with a guy named mike okumian and
he was a banker in the fitness base and
he transacted a handful of uh high
profile deals and after a few
introductions i shared our dilemma and
asked if there was you know he thought
the company could be worth anything and
what he told me next really changed my
life and so i'm loosely paraphrasing but
he said dude you grew from zero to 17
million dollars in profit in two years
and you're now on pace to grow 50 again
this year and i was like yeah i know
we're really tired of it though and
michael's like uh if you continue this
growth at the end of theories like i
could sell this for 150 million easily
and i was like
really
and he was like yeah and if you can
disassociate your brand uh from your
face and maybe get another acquisition
channel going probably even more
and so my job just about hit the floor
right i was used to small business
ownership where when you stop wanting to
do business you bake someone to buy from
you and you're trying to recoup your
costs as much as you can get but this
was something entirely different right
150 million that's not even rich the
generational wealth right and as a
reminder i was 28 all right and so my
wife and i probably had maybe 20 million
bucks saved up at the time but this was
an order of magnitude changing wealth
for us and so after you get off the
phone with michael my head was spinning
and i felt like my world perspective had
shifted forever and it had from that
moment onwards the next two and a half
years all i thought about was how do i
solve this business for 150 million
dollars and interestingly from that
moment onwards my business plateaued
more or less right i mean we grew but
not to the same degree that we were
going before and it could have been
because i was already burned out which
is possible um it could have been
because of macroeconomic forces because
there was a little flu that went around
that affected gyms or could have been
because i wanted to
i shifted from wanting to build
something to wanting to sell it and i
have no idea all i can say is that i
stopped going i stopped growing after
that conversation and so i can
truthfully tell you that 50 or more of
my mental bandwidth for the last two and
a half years was dedicated to the idea
of selling and what's more difficult
about that is i can't really talk about
it publicly right and so it's this kind
of like this burden that you keep in the
back your head that just eats up a lot
of your thoughts that you can't talk
about right and so what happened was all
my decisions changed from
what is going to provide me the most
long-term goodwill with our customers to
what would a potential acquire think of
the decision and would it make the
company more or less valuable and i
think this ultimately hurt my business
uh the heart behind the business had
shifted from the process to the outcome
and over the next year our revenue went
up but our profit dropped because i
thought an acquirer would want to see
lower churn which is true but i made a
terrible mistake and lowered my prices
in an attempt to do so and it ended up
cutting about five million dollars in
profit in the process so i went from 17
million uh in profit on 26 million top
line to the next year i think we did 37
million top line 13.4 million bottom
line which is still obviously not a bad
you know outcome but it it should have
gone the other way should have gone like
19 million on 37. like i said although
we grew by 40 top line my bottom line by
25 and so you know we also thought we
needed to show we were legit and hired a
lot more people to sit around and do
nothing while the core team was still
hustling to get the work done either way
we had we ballooned up to like 135
employees i think at our peak for that
those two entities and so either way
over the course of 2019 uh we pulled me
out somewhat from the fulfillment of
product divisions so that was somewhat
of a win and then in 2020 we committed
to selling the company right so that's
kind of like speeding up to 2020 and we
knew we could tell the story of the
infrastructure cost being something that
ate up margin and that we were still
growing and we were on pace to you know
keep it for a year and show some growth
and then sell it concept so we went to
market in february of 2020 and right as
you guessed it there was this flu that
went around kind of affected our
business a little bit and we had the
option of pulling back but laila and i
were honestly you know uh just like
even-handed about being the gym business
right we wanted to not have that be the
only thing in our lives the bankers
ended up adjusting our expectations and
said you know i think uh and mind you
this was actually we weren't we were no
longer working with uh the guy that was
uh
referenced earlier he actually was just
a council i we ended up using a
different firm i think i think we can
definitely uh help you grow yeah and get
45 for this business right and at this
point we were fine with that we just
wanted out and not really out just more
like we wanted our focus back and so
over the next three quarters our revenue
and profit continued to decline as the
fluid raged on and once the second
shutdown hit the business really hit
rock bottom in q4 so we had gone from
like three to four million dollars a
quarter in profit to like 500 grand in
profit in q4 of 2020 right uh and so the
bankers suggested that we stop the sales
process and try you know try again once
the flu had gone away right but lately
the guy layla and i were kind of yet
again really determined to be out of
pain and so we told them to just you
know keep going with the process and so
they hit up all the private equity firms
again and lo and behold we got a few
replies and some firms were interested
in buying our company at rock bottom
what a surprise right and those replies
after a lot of phone calls and meet and
greets and information requests turned
out to be two offers uh for the company
and then you know for context i i can't
show the actual numbers of the trailing
uh 12 that they came up to this for 2021
but i can tell you that they just
consistently straight line went up um so
basically q4 q1 was kind of like the
bottom of it like december of of q4 of
2020 was like the absolute bottom and
that's really because because there was
almost no hope either i mean like it had
the second round of shutdowns a lot of
gyms had shut down it was just kind of
looking bleak no one decided et cetera
and so i'll bring you up to speed kind
of internally we realized that we would
have to build this business to run on
its own because we didn't know if we
were going to be able to sell it and we
knew we weren't going to like want to
shut it down or something like that
there's too many families that relied on
us too many employees too many customers
like it just it didn't make sense and so
beyond that uh tactically we started an
outbound call center
so that we can have a second channel so
we started to take the steps that we
knew we should do and from the feedback
that we'd had from the first round which
was like you need a second channel it
needs to be
less branded to you etc this is
important to understand uh over the next
12 months i stopped attending all
product meetings all client-facing calls
all client-facing events so i didn't
show up to my events like there was
nothing uh we built an outbound call
team that did 50 of our sales volume and
we promoted a team of generous become
the face of the consulting brand overall
and so the all that remained for me was
a weekly 101 with the ceo a weekly
executive call team that was 90 minutes
and quarterly meetups internally so i
was no longer public facing at all it
was only internal that i was kind of
facing and so now let's get back to
where it was interesting so we signed
and accepted an loi and at this point
you know the profits had gone up
significantly from from kind of the q4
bottom and i have to skip the actual uh
numbers of what was around there i can
just tell you the the overarching number
which was which ended up being uh 46.2
and so here was the decision-making
process and that's what i want to get
into which is like okay so what did you
guys end up doing and why all right
because during this process the business
kind of almost shot out of a gun 2021
and kind of had a really strong rebound
and that's obviously why there was way
more people who were interested first
there was two and then there's two more
interested parties and so we had a
handful of private equity firms that saw
that okay they saw the bottom they saw
the the fast rising back and they're
like wait we could buy a company that
just did you know 15 million in ebitda a
year ago or two years ago and we they
can bank on the fact that it'll probably
do that again let's dive in all right so
that's the back story so these are the
considerations the story slash
milestones that i was telling myself the
money energy head space team resources
future vision best decisions for the
business and ultimately why i decided
what i decided to do i wish i could have
given you more visuals for this but
i
but i did this this already took me a
lot of time to transcribe all my notes
into one presentation and so there was
there was two kind of commodities i and
and it was really kind of having this
like devil's advocate in my head
conversation that was going back and
forth and i even just put these
directional arrows to like what i said
first and then what i responded with
mentally i'm sharing these thoughts with
you because i i want to show that like i
don't think these thoughts ever go away
you know what i mean like i i said and
this is like i mean i was like i need a
sale to be legit you know as an
entrepreneur and then a friend of mine
was like dude you already have seven
successful exits and a handful for
multiple millions right and i was like
well yeah he's like you do seven million
a month right now like you're legit i
was like huh okay uh he's like this is
not a reason to sell business i was like
okay that's fair um i was like but a big
exit is an entrepreneurial rite of
passage right and he's like so jeff
bezos suck elon they're not legit
because they didn't exit their
businesses i was like that is also a
good point i was like well there's kind
of like the four-minute mile component
like there's no e-learning companies
that really sell for you know or
personality-driven brands that that are
selling for these types of numbers not
many at least and so i could prove that
you know these types of models are
soluble i was like well can i just prove
that i have a higher net worth and keep
it i was like that's also not a good
idea or not good reason to sell it you
know another story was like you can't
have more than one thing and so that's
why you should sell but you know in
terms of keeping it it's like well you
just need to level up your skill set
like there are it is not physically
impossible there are other entrepreneurs
who do this and so you just need to be
better and this is just a great growth
opportunity so that's not a good reason
to sell i'm like all right fair i was
like ah it's a big nice few to everybody
who doubted and you know spoke out
against me over the years and then it's
just like you're better than that that's
also not a good reason to sell so i'm
showing this stuff very candidly you can
reinforce uh the lesson of selling my
gyms and so the big lesson there and
this is one that i've spoken about a lot
is that you know sometimes you have to
give up what you have in order to give
up to get the bigger thing that is
unknown so you have to you have to let
go of something that you do know that is
good in front of you for something that
you don't know that could potentially be
great and it kind of hinges on the idea
that what we don't do are the things
that we regret rather than the things
that we do and then fail out that was
that's kind of the story uh there and
the keeping argument that is like well
that might be the wrong lesson to learn
like maybe you needed to exit those
things but it doesn't mean you need to
exit everything it's making sure that we
apply the correct lesson to the story
and that might not be the right lesson
from that story i was like okay that's
fair and then you know finally doing a
sale early selling the the majority
portion of the business would unbrand me
somewhat from the fitness industry
because it's it's still something that
drives me a little nuts uh it might also
be because of how i look so that's
possible just being real like i still
see comments are like hey man i still
find your content valuable even though
i'm not a gym owner and i'm like i
haven't made a gym piece of content in
three years i'm glad
like it's just funny and i consciously
made that decision in 2019 when i
rebranded my podcast uh from jim mulch
secrets uh and i hadn't spoken about
your stuff in a while but i consciously
rebranded it to the game which you can
check out if you want and so my keeping
story around that is like people have
already moved on from that dude like a
handful of comments is not like what
everyone thinks about right you're not
just like some gym dude you already have
the majority of your money is made
outside of gyms now i was like well yeah
but people don't know that and so
anyways these are the stories i was
telling myself at this time right and so
next is kind of like what are the what
are the money money things that i was
telling i was like okay well selling
cash would be nice but the keeping
argument is uh well after it you'll have
a tax event so you'll actually be you'll
have to give a portion of that to the
government it'll actually net decrease
your net worth because you already have
that value in equity and because of the
amount of money you already have so my
wife and i at this point are probably
taking from those two businesses about
45-ish million in dividends it's not
really going to materially change your
your living
which is true other
thing though is that from a selling
perspective it's like i can i can take
that cash and then i can reinvest it and
then all i have to do is just make the
delta right so it's like i can take you
know whatever cash i've received there i
can invest it and then i can build
something else and what i'd have to do
is make up the net difference between
what i do on my own
what my cash grows into
versus what that 66 would be worth in
five years right and so that's the that
the net delta difference and i was like
i feel like that would be still a pretty
strong argument for uh doing the sale
the flip side is what am i going to buy
that's going to make me the same amount
of money that i could from this company
that's clearly going to you know triple
and then you know triple in value and go
back to what it was worth um you know
pre-flu fair argument on the on the
other side it's like well you're super
super concentrated you know
diversification is not a bad
diversification's not a bad idea and
then i quoted warren is a hedge against
ignorance do you feel like you're in
this space do you feel like you don't
like that the companies that you have
you don't know anything about um well no
i actually feel like i know more about
the stuff that i'm doing okay well then
you don't need to have diversification
just go all in on the things that you
know and then they will grow
disproportionately which candidly my
life is an example of that so it's hard
to argue against that point you know
rich people sell wealthy people never
sell another argument for keeping it
yeah uh i could also take out debt and
still continue to own the whole thing
kind of refinance the business and still
keep 100 ownership if i did that but the
problem for me from that perspective is
i knew that i would never do that
because i was already very tired at that
point in running an entire another
process from scratch was something that
i just knew i wasn't going to be willing
to do at least on any short time horizon
i was like okay well you can still do
debt to fuel like m a and start doing
acquisitions and just use that as the
umbrella brand and i was like um well a
couple things one i didn't have the debt
relationships too i didn't know m a at
that level buying majority of
30 40 million you know 10 on the low
side 30 40 on the high side size
companies i was like i don't i don't
that's those are mistakes that could
potentially like undo everything i've
done and i'm just not willing to
uh to quote a friend of mine i bet the
empire for a pot of gold
that was kind of the argument against uh
just using debt to fuel m a the the
final you know keeping argument for for
money was like after tax you're almost
gonna get the same money as if you just
take out debt on the company tax-free
and that is true in theory uh but it's
unknown based on promises from bankers
that's not 100 because a lot of times
they may inflate things uh just fyi side
note bankers will inflate things for you
because they want you to sign on the
dotted line to work with them big
picture consolidated from this is that
like the money wasn't going to change my
life in either direction whether i sold
or i kept it which brought me to the
next one which is energy and heb space
on one level it's like the story is you
can't have more than one thing which i'm
a very big proponent of
the the counter to that is while riches
people own lots of things okay well
that's
also true too
but i think the main difference and i'll
i'll hit on this later is that i think
you can only have one active thing split
split attention is one of the most
dangerous things in entrepreneurship and
i can tell you that when i did split my
attention when i started another company
um and then a third company my revenue
pretty much just continued to flatline
so doing more things just does not like
you have to focus and i think that you
can have multi lots of things that are
going on but you can only have one
active thing so like if i own a building
i'm not active in that i could invest in
apple and i'm not active in that and so
you can't own lots of things it's just
to make sure that what you're owning is
not owning you the next point here is
that selling is a story it's not reality
so it's like the idea that i'm just
gonna like walk away magically and not
care about the company or the employees
or the or the customers it's just that's
a story i'm telling myself in my head
there's still 100 going to be things
that i'm sleeping and you know going to
bed and thinking about the team and the
company and all that stuff and so it's
like you you're not gonna get what you
think you're gonna get from from selling
i was like yeah but i could treat it
like other portfolio companies because
i'm just it's it's kind of
redistributing my net worth you know
accordingly across more more enterprises
and then i could care about them more
evenly whereas here it's
disproportionate in terms of like
lopsided for my net worth
um so i was like okay that's fair
another strong argument for keeping is
like you'll grow faster never selling
just never sell and let it compound tax
free the counter you know for that is
like i just have to outpace that delta
what the cash can make me from investing
plus what i'm going to make on my own uh
versus what that two-thirds share uh
would grow into right that's what i have
to make up if i can make that up then it
would make sense and then this one was
actually from my closest friend he said
what's the objective what problem are
you solving you said i feel like you
just chose the nuclear option of like
okay you know i i want to get headspace
back and so therefore i must uh you know
sell sell two-thirds you know sell some
majority of my company he said why don't
you just match the conditions right like
what is what do you imagine life to be
like
when you have sold majority
uh and then look at what those
conditions look like and then match them
in your current condition and then you
can keep the company and still have the
effective sale that happens in your mind
and uh i was like that is a fair point
but you know my counter is that like i
don't think i can do that
i feel like i'm still i would imagine
it's like having kids where even if
you're spending zero time you know
taking care of the kids even when they
go to college you're still thinking
about them right they're still taking up
shower time they're still taking walk
time they're still taking up morning
coffee chat time right and so those are
kind of some of the head space
considerations i had
team resources the big line here is that
uh you know when you sell sell a company
you you lose the resources right i'm so
used to being on top and having a lot of
leverage in my decisions it's way more
just deciding at this point like i'm not
doing a ton of doing um within any of
the portfolio companies and so
giving up that kind of all those
resources like hey if i'm like hey i
want to go recruit somebody i just go to
the recruiter and say hey can you
recruit this person right if i want to
like go
build a site or i want to go put a book
on amazon i just say hey can you go put
this book on amazon and then it just
gets done right so i would lose that and
that might actually be a big asset for
what i wanted to do next and actually
allow me to move faster right so that is
a is a strong argument for keeping it
right
so these were these are the four
thoughts that i had written down during
the process was like okay well i could
lose the team and but like i could coach
them to become
like the type of people that could work
you know at
acquisition.com it's like well different
needs require a different team that's
not a really good shortcut like there's
different different skills different
backgrounds different experiences etc
that's not really good to try and
retrofit a team that was not designed
for this right you know obviously i love
the team they've been with you since the
beginning this is me arguing to myself
yeah but i need to give them room to
grow and if i'm still there kind of on
top of it they're not going to be able
to like blossom into what i think they
can they can really truly grow into you
could make your employees wealthier you
know if you kept it you could you know
do some sort of esop program there which
is an employee stock ownership program i
was like yeah but they can also become
wealthy um through the stock ownership
plan that the new you know owners would
put in it's like okay that's kind of
move richest guys all said that they
regret selling their teams that's
something i talk to people who are
wealthier than me and they're like they
all regretted doing it the counter to
that is but they're all really wealthy
doing their next thing so
you know i get i and i can understand
the i can understand both sides of it
future and vision uh in terms of like
what i want my my my life to be like
this could be the cash cow to build the
the conglomerate you know that funds all
of these new acquisitions that i built
into my conglomeration i was like yeah
but i could use the cash from the sale
to do the same okay fair
um the version of me that i want to be
can own multiple companies without
running them yes um but you still need
to give you know like
like that's not reality for you right
now and then you know finally here
you'll still care about uh the team the
same and or still care about the company
the same but you'll just have given up
the upside it's like so you're still
gonna do the same mental work and mental
decisions and strategic playing the way
you always are but you'll just give up
the upside on the counter that i was
like yeah but i'll still have four
companies rather than one and that's
going to really distract me from what i
want to do ultimately which is
acquisition.com and so um that was kind
of like the future and vision component
of it all right and so
the last thing before i'll tell you why
i made the decision that i did is the
business component you know on one side
i was like okay do you want to do what
is required to get to 200 million i
could just do the playbook that the
private equity is going to do because i
know what their playbook is and so i
could just do that so that's an argument
right you know businesses always go up
in value over time right unless they
don't in which case they become sellable
so it's like if you keep it and it goes
up then like you would still own the
thing and it would be making more money
in the future so the value goes up and
you get dividends the whole time which
is why business ownership is very
lucrative
but in case it doesn't in which case you
don't make any money and the thing that
you have has no value right
um
you know they don't have a magic pill
they're not gonna do anything you don't
know how to do it's like yes but they're
gonna put all their focus on it and i am
not because i'm doing other things that
i want to do you know imagine what
you're going to learn watching them do m
a if we sell it
yeah but you don't need to learn you
know learn from them to do that so
that's a different you know perspective
on it
if you
want to do
what they do just buy it from yourself
you know and have it have your your new
self buy it from your old self still go
through the transaction mentally uh
install the same incentives run the same
playbook as them but just own the whole
thing right
um
but i really thought about that i was
like i feel like that's it's fear that's
driving that decision fear of losing
what i have
and uh it's like hey you need to have
the skill uh of being passive well i
already have that it's just not i just
don't feel like i have that about a
company that i founded myself
and then um you can always just use the
transition plan that i already designed
during diligence that i presented to
them and just execute it yourself and
it's like yeah i can do that in theory
but i don't know if it's going to be
that clean and so you know the one line
summary for for
this is like do i think selling or
keeping it is the best decision for the
business i think that if i uh keep the
company i will increase my net worth
more do i think the company will realize
its potential if i keep it maybe maybe
not um i think that the people who
were going to potentially buy it had a
very good
skill set in growing companies of this
size they're more experienced in m a
than me and so
i think that the business would benefit
from that all right so what decision did
i ultimately make i'll give you my quick
one-line summary of kind of selling and
keeping after giving you all those
different variables uh for selling
anything that distracts from my
berkshire hathaway will be a net loss
so get into a better boat and this is
just the classic example of like
everybody told me that i was crazy when
i was when i sold my gyms to start the
licensing company uh gym launch but it
was because like what they saw in front
of them was six gyms that were making
money and i was 26 or something
and they were you know like why would
you give something up that you worked so
hard for and it's obviously making money
and it's because like in some way it's
like i have to believe in me more than
they do because in their minds maybe
that's what they think i'm limited to
capacity wise and i think that i can do
more uh and so that's the you know the
argument for selling the argument for
keeping which is also very compelling is
you know become the person who can grow
a cash compounding conglomerate without
ever selling ever you know warren
buffett never sells wholly owned
companies he also says get into the best
boat so he has two pieces of advice that
contradict themselves and uh they're
both very good and very very fair
so what decision did i ultimately make
right so everyone has a plan until
there's a check in front of them to walk
away for 46.2 so um
it's one thing to say no in theory and
it's another thing to say no and you're
one email away from that you know money
right and so uh these are kind of the
soft decision frameworks that i applied
so the first one is that i had to
acknowledge that there was no wrong
answer right so i knew that if i did
either of those directions ultimately i
was still always going to be very
wealthy and none of it was going to make
any material difference in my life and
whatever decision i tried to go to
winners win and i would have probably
executed them either way and it probably
wouldn't matter i knew also from a
happiness perspective that i'll probably
be happy in either direction and you
know rationalize
whatever decision i made either way that
was like first and foremost none of this
matters the second one is like okay well
you know
is it i could still make a better
decision versus a worse decision even
though they both might be quote or right
decision um which has just reminded me
of this the story of the boy and the
horse you know father buys a a boy a
horse everyone in the town says that's
amazing the wise man says time will tell
um then the kid falls off the horse and
breaks his leg and then everyone's like
oh that's terrible you bought the kid
the horse and then the wiseman says time
will tell and then army comes around and
recruits all the young guys to go to the
military and then you know half them die
and then everyone's like oh my god that
horse was a blessing and then the
watchman says time will tell and so
ultimately you kind of get where this is
going right that you don't really know
whether something was good or bad until
the day you die and once you die it
won't matter food for thought noting
that the three hardest decisions in my
life uh quitting my job to start my gym
selling the gyms to start gym launch and
then potentially selling gym launch
prestige and allen
to start acquisition.com and go all in
on that uh each of those are the three
hardest decisions of my life and it's
because i had to give up something that
i knew that gave me status that people
uh give me praise for um that most
people considered big material successes
for something that was potentially
bigger but completely unknown so some
the bird in the hand versus the two in
the bush and the thing is is that the
hardest decisions i think in life are
giving up the one that's in your hand
for the two that are in the bush um and
so it's like you have to take big risks
sometimes to take the next kind of like
quantum leap you know take the next uh
jump in order of magnitude so these are
the three hardest decisions i've ever
made in my life and i would say that in
order they were most difficult quitting
my job second most difficult
selling my gyms third most difficult uh
selling these companies are my majority
interest in those companies so i i i
give this for context because i think
that a lot of people who are listening
to this like you're probably in one of
these decisions where you have one in
your hand and there's two in the bush
like i think the hardest decision of
entrepreneurship or really life in
general is when do you give that up when
do you not take the rational move and
take take the upside one and so for me i
just knew that regret would be more
guaranteed from paths not taken rather
than failed execution
this is a question that i get from layla
and it was uh one of the things that we
both thought about a lot which is what
am i most afraid of like which of these
decisions makes me the most afraid
keeping it or selling it and for me
selling it was the thing i was most
afraid of because i was like what if i
can't recreate what i've done what if
it's you know what it's a flash in the
pan what if i'm a one-hit wonder which
was silly anyways because we already
have seven other businesses we've sold
but i'm just telling you these are the
thoughts you have right and so yeah like
what am i most afraid of that was what i
was most afraid of and so finally our
second to last i had my 85 year old self
test which i have i've talked a lot
about and i'll talk more about which is
uh i run and i'm doing this almost like
without knowing now because it's been so
ingrained because probably the most
effective distance framework i've had in
my life and so i'm just going to keep
using it which is like what does 85 year
old me think about this decision and the
honest truth is that 85 ruled me in this
decision was useless because he was like
it's not going to matter anyways
do the thing that it texts you and you
know it's like what are you and like i'm
talking 85 year old selfies like what
are you afraid of and it's like that i'm
not going to be successful if i do the
next thing it's like well that's not a
very good reason not to do it and so i
was like okay i guess that's fair
does who you want to become
you know i was like well i really want
to be a rational investor i want to be
somebody who makes rational decisions
he's like yeah
but you know the ups like you're limited
on your upside in this and so like if
you believe that your life can be bigger
than this then you're guaranteed to not
get it if you don't take the big jumps
i was like okay that's fair and so that
was kind of like the main shifts that i
got from my 85 year old self this was
ultimately the one thing that mattered
most and i'll tell you finally why i
decided to do what i did the next thing
that i do will be 10x or 100 times as
big and if anything takes my intent from
that it will be a net loss i would hate
to look back and think i was holding on
too hard to what i had and didn't have
enough faith or i could have if i took
the leap and believed before sing and so
at every level the fog is bigger but so
too is the reward and so like as you you
know climb the mountain right if you
fall there's further to hit the ground
um in terms of your perceived failures
but like you still have to take jumps to
hit the next mountaintops and so i think
that was ultimately
the biggest reason for why
we decided to do what we did
and i'll tell you one interesting thing
which is that like i felt the loss of
the business but i didn't feel the gain
of the money the money really i didn't
feel it at all um and so that was kind
of interesting so i felt like the loss
of resources i did feel some level of
relief for about three days and then it
was back to normal which was nice and
then now that we are
back in this
in this in this season of building i can
tell you 100
that this was 100 the right decision um
i you know obviously i'm going to
rationalize whatever decision i make but
after really thinking through all of the
different angles
this was
the the right call uh because i can
already see and feel the momentum it's
so nice to be back in the trenches again
i love building things um i am a builder
and so uh it's great to build not only
my own business but to build all the
portfolio companies and so i'm just i'm
learning so much more i'm being exposed
to a lot more things which allows me to
make more lessons and you know the the
mission of acquisition.com is to
document and share the best practices of
building world-class businesses and so
you're like why does alex make these
videos part of it is because of that
like i wish that elon and i wish that
that jeff and i wish that
you know warren you know wrote books and
made youtube channels right of like what
they were thinking about at every given
you know part of their journey because i
hope that 30 40 50 years from now like
we were like man if you look at alex in
his 30s what he was deciding what he was
thinking about and looking in his 40s
what he was deciding what he was
thinking about i want i wanted these
videos to be kind of like proof of that
so that they could hopefully help others
retrace the path but i am very very
confident that the decision that we made
was the right one i just can't tell you
the amount of like creative energy it
was like the moment we actually made the
decision it was like my future unlocked
again like i couldn't see past
making the decision to sell it was like
it was like i had to make this decision
before the rest of the opportunities uh
in my life opened up and so um i think i
made a tweet that was shared a zillion
times which is like the heaviest thing
in the world is an iron or gold but it's
an unmade decision and so i think
and i made that during the time when i
was when i was making this decision to
sell or not and so i think that for a
lot of us there's these unmade decisions
that weigh us down and like they eat up
so much of our mental capacity that we
just need to free ourselves up and and
do it uh and pull the trigger those are
the soft decision farmers that i allowed
myself to to think through um and if you
didn't catch in the beginning i have
nothing to sell you i have no
masterminds then coaching programs or
mentorships for sale i do have a 99 cent
book if you want to give 66 cents of
that to to amazon uh it's got three
thousand five star reviews it's the
first of ten books that i'm making kind
of detailing the process of of scaling a
business i have a course that goes with
that that's for free you don't even have
to opt in for it so it's not like an
email collection it's just i think that
the highest leverage thing that most
people can do is is improve their offer
that's the first place that i start with
all the businesses that we take on that
we invest in and so if you're curious
like what we actually do we we invest in
companies that are doing between one and
ten million in profit uh typically
within uh the e-learning or service
space so uh you know chains of of brick
and mortar service businesses that want
to license or want to franchise or
people who already have a niche uh that
they have to find out that they do
business services too so it's like oh
i'm i'm good at you know
bookkeeping i'm good at helping lawyers
improve their practices whatever stuff
like that are the types of niche
licensing businesses that we go after
because that's our playbook and so we
work with those businesses to scale them
to you know 30 50 million plus and i
make these videos for everyone else to
hopefully get there
so that we can have the opportunity to
um you know invest in your business and
help you help you go to the next level
so anyways this is part one uh this was
just like the thoughts behind the
decision i will do another video or two
in terms of what i learned about the
negotiation process i learned about
explaining what i learned about the
sales process overall
in other videos this one i wanted to
walk through kind of what i was thinking
about for myself and everyone for why we
decided to
to do that and then ultimately
sell the two-thirds stick hope you found
value in this and if you did watch
another video and i'll see in the next
ones